クジャクとかね 大型の鳥いるんですね
来てなんかどっかに木の枝に座るんだと
座ったらそれ折れちゃうんだと
で あ そういうことで人が怖がるんだと
そういう風にいろいろ全然怖くなかったんだと
で そういうことでも お釈迦様は後で悟ってから
そういうお経を教えながらおっしゃったかったのは
やっぱり人間というのはこの幻覚
真っ暗闇の中で ものすごい枝が折れた音を聞いた途端
どんな人間でももうびっくりして飛び上がっちゃうんです
その認識はその人の文化によって違うんですね
例えば自分の国の文化だったら
この子供たちの間でいろいろ物語あります
いろんな鬼たちがいるんだと
人食い鬼やら で そういうのはもう夜出てくるんだと
で 必ず出てくると まあ枝を一つ折るとかね
そういうことをするんだ
それで怖くなって まあ鬼が人を殺してしまうんだと
もしそういう子供が まあそういう文化の子供がね
夜そういう音を聞いたら
まあやっぱりなんとか鬼が出ましたと
と そう決めちゃうし 日本の人はそれなりに日本の文化によって何かを考えて怖くなったりする
だから全てそういう もう幻覚だけの世界で生きてるんですね
だからいくらかこのコントロールされている世界にいるのはそれほど大した世界ではないんだけど
問題ないんだけど 実際に我々は科学の世界で生きているんじゃないんですね
あの人間の感覚の世界で生きているんですね
だからさらにひどいんです
我々の生き方は 人間いくら科学を勉強したっても
科学者にならないんですね
正真正銘の それでも自分の好き嫌い入っちゃうんですね
偉そうに私にも文句言われますけどね
よく勉強しているんだと自分たちがと
私はあまり気にしないんだから
なんか馬鹿にして喋ってるんだからね
で じゃあ医学を知ってるんだったら
本人が癌になったと思ったら
なんであんなあれほど驚くんですかね？なんであれほど心配そうにしたり
悩んだりするんですかね
科学的な事実だったら癌ですか
そう ああそう わかったと
それで終わるでしょうに
なぜならば 細胞のこと知っているならば
いつでも癌細胞は癌になる可能性あるんだから
冷静にいればいいでしょうに
やっぱり人間にはそれできないんですね
人間 科学知識で生きていないんですね
全部幻覚で生きてるんです
だからその幻覚作ることも心にはできるんです
だから我々一番気をつけなくちゃいけないのは私たちの認識
知識なんです あれは真っ赤な嘘なんです
私たちの知識っていうのは
人に殴られて痛いというのは嘘じゃないんだ
痛いんだから それについて頭の中に出てくる考え方は全部嘘なんです
人に殴られて痛かった
まあ痛かった それで終わり
でもこの人私のことに恨み持ってるんだと
この人は精神的な病気だと
ああだこうだといろんなことを思ったりするでしょうね
あるいは私はなんで不幸な人間かと
今日はついてないんだと
朝からもいろんな不幸なことがあったと
その上 また人にも殴られたんだと
そういうふうないろんなことを頭で考えるでしょうね
そういうのは全部根拠ない真っ赤な嘘なんです
事実で言えば ただ殴られた
それ痛かったと そこら辺はコントロールされている知識なんです
なぜならば 殴られたところのエネルギーは決まってるし
体の受ける量も決まってるし
痛みもこれぐらいっていうのは決まってるんですから
ですからできれば だから科学の世界ですごい認めているのは
このコントロールされている知識なんです
自由な知識ではないんです
自由な知識の場合は 人間も思い存分幻覚を作って
それで生きてるんですね
ですから 人間の知識も当てにならないし
人間の自由な認識も全く当てにならないものだと
そういうことで しっかりした智慧を得なくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
で なんでそういう話をしたんですかというと
仏教では瞑想という世界が出てくるんですね
瞑想という世界で ヴィパッサナー瞑想であろうとサマーディ瞑想であろうといわゆるあのサマーディ瞑想っていうのはインド宗教共通的な修行で
ヴィパッサナー瞑想は仏教だけの特別に発見された瞑想法で
仏教では両方もやるんです
サマーディもヴィパッサナーも
で そのサマーディ瞑想の場合も
ヴィパッサナー瞑想とはちょっと違って
よくわかること一つあります
特色が 眼耳鼻舌身に頼らんこと
眼耳鼻舌身から得る情報を正しいと
と思わない それで眼耳鼻舌身を土台にして
その情報チャンネルを乗り越えられるかないかと頑張ってみるんです
ですから もし眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報の次元を飛び出したら
そこで第一禅定が生まれるんです
ですから いわゆる次元違う欲界・色界・無色界と分かれているのはそういうわけなんです
で 皆様知っている言葉で言うならば
この瞑想を妨げるこの五蓋
五つの蓋があるんですね
心を抑えている その五蓋の一番目は欲
貪欲ですね カーマ・チャンダという
欲でもいいし 貪欲でもいいし
むさぼりですね カーマっていうのは眼耳鼻舌身に頼ることなんです
そこは大したことないんだと
すごい狭い世界だと理解すれば
もう瞑想 サマーディの方に心が行っちゃうんです
なぜ我々の瞑想はうまくいかないかというと
いくら瞑想したっても体のことは大事にするんですね
瞑想は後回しなんですね
早く瞑想終わらないかと思っちゃうんです
なんで早く瞑想終わらないかと思っちゃうかと
瞑想終わってすぐ何か他のことあるんだから
やること 結局メインテーマが体を楽しませることなんですね
それだったらもうそんな瞑想ではサマーディは生まれません
で 朝瞑想するとすると
やっぱり7時に終わらなくちゃ
なんでですか 朝ごはん食べるために
それだったら瞑想にならないんです
なぜならば みんな目的サマーディ作ろうじゃなくて
とにかく7時までなんとかやって
もう朝ごはん食べたい
そこで時間スケジュール
タイムテーブルを作って
じゃあ8時から9時半まで瞑想して 9
時半から11時までこういうこういう本を読みますとかね
スケジュールを作ると
まあどうしても欲界の次元を超えてないんですね
そういう気持ちで世の中の人間瞑想しているんだから
サマディの体験っていうのは万人に一人しかない
これも瞑想する人々の間で
で 2番目は怒りの蓋なんですね
怒りに心は 蓋っていうのは蓋なんですね
蓋という漢字です だから怒りで心を押さえられている
蓋をかけていると 怒りも同じくこの体から入る情報の関わりなんですね
見えるものについて嫌だと思うことは怒りであって
聞くものについて嫌だと思うことは怒りであって
長い時間座っていると体が痛いでしょうという
それ嫌だなと思って それ怒りであって
ですから 怒りもやっぱり体に関して生まれるものであって
欲界を離れていない 瞑想をあんまりやりたくない
やる気が出てこないとかいう場合も
じゃああなた何がやる気がありますかと聞いたら
具体的にやる気があるものいっぱい出るでしょうね
それは全部欲界の体の中心のものなんです
それだったら瞑想したっても意味がないし
成長はしない サマディは生まれません
次にある問題は昏沈睡眠
それも体のことなんです
で 見て楽しみたい 聞いて楽しみたい
食べて楽しみたいと言っちゃうと体が疲れるんです
見ると目が疲れる 聞くと耳が疲れる
なぜならば物質とぶつからなくちゃいけないんだから
殴られることと同じなんです
僕は今日朝 このティッシュ一つ
こうやって捕捉して耳を掃除しようと思って
で いくらか掃除して もっとしっかり掃除しようと思って
この耳の中に入れたんです
そこで耳の中 あれ 何て言いますか
膜があるんでしょ それに触れちゃったんですね
で 飛び上がってびっくり
痛くて いきなり あ 痛いと
ですから そこは音を触れる場所だから
もうほんのちょっとティッシュちょっと触れるだけでも痛いんです
そこで音を触れる時も同じく
すっごく痛くて疲れるんです
目も疲れる 鼻も疲れる
体にものを触れると疲れるんです
なんか座ってみてください
座るのは楽だなと思ってるでしょうね
座ってみたらどうなるんですかね
結局疲れるでしょう 寝ていることは楽だなと
寝てみてください 最終的には疲れるんですね
体が ですから この体のことしか気になってない人々には
必ずしも出てくるのは何ですか？疲れと眠気なんです
ですから この昏沈睡眠というのは瞑想しない人にあるもので
瞑想する人にとっては出てこないんです
睡眠ってのは それ体はだるいし
疲れるし ああまあ嫌だ
もうもうダメだというふうに感じちゃうし
瞑想する時でもすごく眠気が出てくるってことは
やっぱり体のことを気になっている
で それ次のあれ 何でしたっけ？狂悔
ウッダッチクって上狂と狂悔ですね
上狂と狂悔も出てくるのは
この欲界に囚われてるんだからなんです
上狂っていうのは頭混乱状態
どうして見たり聞いたり感じたりして
それを判断したりするでしょうね
一つも正しい判断ではないし
自分が綺麗だと思うのは他の人綺麗じゃないと思っちゃうし
そこですごい混乱が生まれるんですね
当たり前で すごい混乱が生まれる
例えばこの 今流行ってるのは
例えば紫色の服が今流行ってるんだよと思ったら
みんなじゃあ紫色をいろいろ探さなくちゃいけないでしょうね
いろんな冊子を見たり
いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないし
その情報耳に入るたびに心が混乱するんです
ですから この上狂っていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報に頼ってるんだから生まれるのであって
狂悔も同じことで もう何やっても結局失敗ですね
正しくはないでしょうね
喋っても完璧に喋れません
なぜなら私の判断ばっかり知ってるんだから
その判断は間違ってるんだから
歩いたって私勝手に正しいと思ってる方法で歩いてるんだから
後ろから聞いてる人がこの人邪魔ですよって言われるかもしれませんし
ですから人間何やったってもそれは不完全だから
それで納得いかないんですね
やらなかったらよかったんではないかと
すぐ思っちゃうんです
それからあれやっておけばよかったんではないかとまた思っちゃうんです
ですから やったことについて
もうやらなかった方がよかったと思うことと
やらなかったことについて
やっぱりあれやっておけばよかったと
そういうふうに心が痛めると
物質の世界に ゲンミンビー出身の世界にも関わりがあるんです
それは常苦と苦海というんです
それで心は抑えられているんです
で  5番目の蓋は疑と言うんです
疑い 疑はあるのはまだ当たり前であって
何一つも見てないんだから
知ってないんだから 人間には誰にでも自分を知ってることに自信ないでしょ
私はこれを知ってる 任せてちょうだいと言えますかね
全然言えないでしょ だから疑だらけなんです
そういうことで この五蓋というものは
その なんていますか 我々はこのゲンミンビー出身の欲世間
欲界に囚われているんだから現れる
もうトラブルなんです
それで心が超一流レベルに行かないんです
超一流レベルに 瞑想はできない
ヴィパッサナー瞑想もできないし
サマーディ瞑想もできないし
全部きれいさっぱり欲世間を捨てなくちゃいけないんです
無意味だと バカバカらしいんだと
捨てた人にだけ瞑想の見込みがあるんです
捨てられたらもう確実サマーディが生まれるので
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
なぜならば そこぐらい捨てられる人には
所詮もうすごい智慧があるんです
そこで我々の心がこのコントロールされている世界で活動している
それに暇があると幻覚をする
その二つがやってないんです
で コントロールされている知識でいるならば
それ問題ないんだけど
それでも長時限にはいかないんですね
例えば科学者やら医学者やら
そういう学者たちが その世界がすっごい狭いんですね
自分の世界から一歩出れば何もわからなくなっちゃうんです
で 彼らがずっと 24時間コントロールされている知識の中にいるんです
あまり幻覚は作りませんだけど
世界から離れたらもう何もできないし
一般の人々はもうあまり勉強したり
知識的なことをやりたくないんですね
もう仕事のために何とかちょっとやるんだけど
すぐそれやめて普通の現実世界に戻っちゃう
ですから この普通の心はそういう働きですね
そこで じゃあ心に徹底的に事実だけ教えてあげればどうです
というのはヴィパッサナー瞑想
そうすると心が変わるんだと
智慧が生まれるんだと
サマーディ瞑想っていうのは
心はこの現認比出身の世界次元から上に持っていけばどうですか
いわゆる純粋認識はいかがでしょうかと
汚れてる認識ではなくて
そう すごい差があるんです
事実見せてあげればどうですかっていうのはヴィパッサナーです
心には純粋認識してあげればどうですかっていうのはサマーディ瞑想
なぜ仏教ではサマーディ瞑想で悟れないかというと
純粋認識は認めます それは純粋認識だから
もうぴったし正しいんだと
でも認識には変わりはないんですね
それでなんとかなるかというと
何もならないんだと ただ
ある人が他の人にできないことをやったと
すごい それで終わるんですね
我々は走れません 滑れませんだけど
雪の上で ある人々がそこで雪の上で滑っちゃって金メダルもらったと
純金でもないんだけど
で 私たちにはできない
じゃあ金メダル取った人はだからなんかなるの？それで
だからって別になんもなりませんよ
いくらお金もらうかもしれませんし
みんなにちやほやされるかもしれませんし
それだけのことで終わっちゃうんですね
ですから 純粋認識得ることも
なんとなくオリンピックで金メダルもらうもののように
ものすごいことなんです
普通の人にできるものじゃないんです
で まあこれ全部アビダンマの最後に出てくるものばっかり今日なんで喋ってるか自分でもわかりませんだけど
で これから全部明確に項目ごとに出てくるんです
一旦いくらか知っておいた方が
後の説明に役に立つかもしれません
サマーディ瞑想のやり方なんですけど
この音を中心に瞑想もできるし
目を中心に瞑想できるし
で パーリ 仏教では出てくるのはこの何かこの見るものを作るんですね
対象 色を一番見やすいんだから
で 色も原色 青とか赤とか黄色いとか白いと
その四つの色を一つ選んで
まあちょっとまあ十センチ十二センチぐらいの輪を作って
一つのこの そういう瞑想するための道具を作るんですね
あるいは土 地水火風 物質だから
それの道具一つ作っちゃうんですね
で まあ水を見て瞑想することもできます
だからなぜ水を見るんですかというと
水を見ると水の幻想を体験することが可能なんです
土を見たら 地水火の地の幻想を見られることは可能なんですね
そういうものには地の幻想おいしい
水の場合は水の幻想おいしい
空気を見て瞑想するんだったら
風の幻想しやすい 見やすいです
それから光というものも直接見たり瞑想されたりはするんです
で それは後で説明出ますから
例えばこの円を紙でもいいんだけど
作って 適当な大きさで自分の手と指一本ぐらい長さというんだから
それぐらいの長さで横で円を作って
例えば青い色 あるいは黄色い色に作って
もういろいろ準備してあるんだ
すっごい準備があるんです
その前にもう食べ物をちゃんと体に合う食べ物を食べて
もう体を清らかにして
すごく体綺麗にして 瞑想する場所をものすごい徹底的に綺麗にして
気持ちいい環境を作って
自分の頭混乱する人々いるんだったら
その人々から綺麗に離れて
世俗的な関わりから全部離れて
で どこかで腰をかけて
あまり結核はしないんです
そうすると長い時間瞑想できませんから
あの対象をじーっと見ているんです
何も考えないで見ているんです
その時にいろんなことを考えちゃいますから
言葉を使うんですね 青い色を見てるんだったら
青い色を青い色と あるいは青い青いと
なんとかそういう適当な言葉をずーっと念じちゃう
念じちゃうと 頭にはもう結構このそれに邪魔されて
言葉で妄想できなくなったり
どんどんどんどん見ていると
目を閉じてもそれ見えるようになっちゃうんです
全く同じもの そういう風にこの純粋認識の方に持っていっちゃうんです
なぜそう見えるかというと
例えば目を開けて見ても
これ青い色やと判断するのは頭だから
頭がコントロールされてるんだから
目から情報取れてこれな
来なきゃ頭寝ちゃうんです
いずれうぶんしんの方へ入るでしょうと
情報ないと心がうぶんしんになる
寝るんです ですから 目を開けて見ていると見えるんでしょうし
で 見えると言っても 目から情報入る
入った情報を頭で映像する
映像化する 情報に入ってるんです
頭で勝手に映像化するんだから
頭には何でも映像化できるでしょ？自由に
それでこの対象をどんどん見て見て見て
一日 二日 三日 一ヶ月かかるかわかりませんだけど
大体二時間 三時間 四時間瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
して もしお腹がすいたり
なんとかしたならば 適当に何か食べて
早く誰とも喋らないで
また来て また続かなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると我々の認識が勉強しちゃうんですね
あ これ目を閉じても見えるようになる
頭はその認識を作るようになる
それから瞑想に入る それからもっと落ち着いてる場所に行って
部屋にいるんだったら部屋の鍵でもかけて座って
その頭で見える対象を見て
ずーっと同じ言葉で繰り返して瞑想するんです
そうすると さらに純粋な認識が生まれてくるんです
この青い色を見ていたならば
その人には次にこの青い色の青い光に見え始めるんです
それは頭だけの働き でも決して眼耳鼻舌身が頼ってるならば絶対見えないんです
見えるのは目で見えるものだよというバカな考え方を持ってるんだったら
絶対見えないんです 見えることのということも頭の働きだよと
心の働きだよと言ってる人にだけ
それは具体的にものすごい強烈に青い光
純粋青い光見え始めちゃうんです
その光見えたら意識がさらに強くするんです
光はわずかに見えるんです
最初は わずかに見えること
そこに集中して かなり大きく見えるところまで
またさらに瞑想する そうすると結構大きくこの光が見え始める
見え始めたら心にこの第一禅定が生まれるんです
いわゆる一体感が生まれるんですね
その純粋認識の世界はサマーディの世界なんです
それまた上上上上たくさんあるんです
色界と無色界とかね そういう人の心っていうのはかなり強烈に強い
欲界には耐えられない
どんなことやりますかというと
一つは認識のこのチャネルをね
第6チャネルにする 仏教でいえば七番目のチャネルなんですけどね
まあ一応この一般的に言えば第6チャネルを開けるっていうことなんですね
目がなくても見えると
耳がなくても聞こえると
窓口にこの五つの六つの窓口がなくても
もう別に認識は生まれるんだ
ということでいろいろ技もできるんです
技というのは 例えば空気を見て瞑想して
その体験を得た人には
壁を見ても壁の空気を見ることができるんです
目を開けたっても閉めたっても同じことなんです
そうすると 壁の向こう側のことを見たいと思ったら
それ見えちゃうんです
そういうのは別に役に立ちませんだけど
そういういろいろ噂はできるんです
で これからその心の働き
心の過程 認識過程 次にジャーナヴィティと出ているんです
もし人が瞑想してその次元を飛び出す場合
心のどんな過程があるかっていうことは
このテキストに出てくるジャーナヴィティ
マッガヴィティなんですね
で 説明は百八百九ページに
出てくると思います このジャーナの禅定の場合は
この明瞭不明瞭という分別はないんです
全部明瞭なんです 一応分別ない
明瞭といったら分別ですから
明瞭不明瞭という関係はないんです
で わざと修行しなきゃ育てなきゃ現れない心の次元なんです
認識の次元なんです そこでこのリストにありますか？どこかに書いて
前のリストかな この前配ったリストにあったでしょうね
もしかすると あったっけ？書いてない
あ 前のリストはやっぱり認識だけですね
人が瞑想していると 瞑想して
まあそろそろ禅定が現れようとする
この禅定っていうのは
この次元を破る瞬間なんです
例えば目で見て それから目を閉じて
この光対象が見えたっても
もしかすると破ったことじゃないんですね
そこで急にこの一体感が生まれてきて
なんか心がなんかこの
なんか何て言いますかね
今まで自分の意識で心を認識していたんだけど
急に意識がなくなっちゃって
自動的に動くようになる瞬間があるんですね
自分で何もやるわけじゃなくて
ただ認識が流れてしまっちゃうんだというふうな
この一体感といえば一体感であって
自分の意識が消えちゃう瞬間なんですね
瞑想ではずっと自分の意識で頑張ってるんです
ある瞬間自分の意識がなくなっちゃって
流れちゃうんですね その瞬間のことを言ってるんです
で そこでまあもしあの我々車でもいいんだけど
まあ坂の上り坂道を押してるんだと
上り坂道車を押してるんだったら
ずーっと押さなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでまあどんどん強く押さなくちゃいけないんです
上り坂だから 押して押して
どこかでちょっと平らなところあるんだと
その平らなところに行った瞬間で
今もうずっと力強く押していたんだから
あの辺で押さなくなっても
きちんと車が自分で行っちゃうんです
そのような瞬間が心に生まれるんです
ずっと自分で意識していたのに
ある瞬間 自分の意識じゃなくて
サッと心が流れると その瞬間が禅定が出た瞬間で
心の次元が飛んだ瞬間なんです
で どうせここ認識はまず始まるのはバワンガでしょうし
バワンガの心の次にバワンガ・チャラナという心が生まれる
それから この前の授業のリストを見ると
似ている言葉でしょうと思いますけど
バワンガは有分心 バワンガ・チャラナは動ですね
動揺心 有分動揺心 有分動揺心の次に
バワンガ・ウパッチーダという心が生まれるんです
これ三つも有分心なんです
有分心がちょっと動揺して
これでもこっちの場合も動揺するんだけど
あまりにも動揺激しいんだから
次の心は有分心ではない
だから有分心消える前の心にバワンガ・ウパッチーダと言うんです
バワンガが消える瞬間
次に生まれるのは 慰問・隠転
それから認識しなくちゃいけないんだから
慰問・隠転心が生まれるんですね
これはパーリ語だったらマノドワラワッジャナ
で このマノドワラワッジャナっていうのは慰問・隠転で
これから意で 慰問で認識しようという働きですからね
そこで準備の心が生まれる
慰問で認識する準備が生まれる
この認識する準備が生まれる
その前の心にバワンガ・ウパッチーダ
あるいは遮断心というのは
これで有分が終われるんだから遮断心と言うんです
大体言葉っていうのはそういう戦後関係で作っている言葉なんです
で あの慰問隠転のVPを道を見たところで皆様知ってると思いますけど
この慰問隠転生まれたら次何が生まれるかというと即行心生まれるんです
心はすぐ働き出すんです
あの原因非生成と違って
そこで次にあるのは必ず即行心なんですね
即行心っていうのはパーリ語でジャマナと言うんですね
走る心なんですけど 走り心は大体七つぐらい埋めなく
現れなくちゃいけないんです
同じ心 その同じ心七つ生まれちゃったならば
普通の意識と何の違いもないんです
何の違いもないんだから
違う言葉使うんです で
ジャバナジャバナと一応七つ生まれるんですね
それ禅定が生まれる時のこと
そこで即行心がどんな心がするかと
皆様のこのリストにあるんです
これ瞑想している人だから
あの欲界の何心？カーマーアーチャリクシェラチッタ
えーと専心八あります
欲界の善心の八あります
その八の中で一つで即行心をするんです
一つで言ったってもほとんどこの四つだと思いますけど
このあの知恵相応心だと思いますけどね
こういう特別な名前使ってるんです
で 全部即行心なんです
欲界の専心なんです 瞑想しているんだから
でも一番目の即行心にパリカッマと呼ぶんです
パリカッマっていうのは一生懸命瞑想しているという
まあ準備しているという意味なんですね
いわゆる まあ準備準備する心が
次っていうのはまた同じ心が生まれるんだけど
その心にウパチャーレと言うんです
ウパチャーレというのは近寄るんだと
なんか次の心はなんかこれから生まれて生まれようとしてる禅定に近寄る
似ているようになっちゃう
それはウパチャーレと呼んで
次にアノーマーという三番目の心が生まれる
アノーマーっていうのはほとんど似ているという状態
サマーディにほとんど似ている状態
で 次の心もサマーディにほとんど似ている状態
でもその心の名前はゴートラブーと呼んで
ゴートラブーという心が生まれたら
次に禅定の心が生まれちゃう
で このリスト 今僕が黒板で書いたリストから見ると
全部七つ出てこなくちゃいけないでしょうし
ですからまた二つ残ってるんだから
その場合も同じ禅定禅定の心が